[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look then at
what is on the front pages time to see
what's making the headlines with the
journalist and broadcaster Jenny
clearman and the home Affairs editor of
the times Matt dathan uh welcome to both
of you with us from now until just
before midnight so as ever to those
front pages let's start with the Daily
Mail which says that plans will be
announced tomorrow to House channel
migrants on former military bases
disused ships and barges that's also the
front page lead in The Times hundreds of
migrants to be housed in a giant barge
the paper says the financial times
reports that the chancellor Jeremy Hunt
is poised to give the NHS three billion
pounds in new funding that would impart
go towards satisfying recent pay demands
from staff but the paper also says a
further pay dispute with teachers is
likely
a review commissioned after a doctor
took her own life has found that
University Hospitals Birmingham NHS
trust was run with a mafia-like culture
that's the lead for the Metro well the
express leads with a report which it
says shows a shocking loss of Faith by
the public in the NHS
the eye has news of victory for Gary
lineker in his dispute with hmrc the tax
office you and me over how he's been
paid for his presenting work the Scott
trust which owns the guardian apologizes
for its Founders historical historical
even links to slavery on the paper's
front page
The Daily Mirror pictures actor sir
David Jason with the daughter he's only
just discovered that he has
and the star tells us that apparently
bofins don't like being called boffins
so we won't call them boffins what do
they want to be called anyway a reminder
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us or our
guests so let's go straight to Jenny
Clement and Matt dathan who are here
um let's go shall we to the financial
times first of all and certainly this is
something that the Prime Minister was
questioned about today at the liaison
committee how are you going to pay for
NHS pay settlements and lo and behold
here's the financial times Jenny
suggesting that Jeremy Hunt will dip
into the treasury coffers to offer some
more
yes well we know that nurse nurses and
ambulance workers are going to be voting
on whether or not to accept uh this pay
deal uh that the government made last
month or wanted to make uh with the
unions to stop all of the strikes or at
least the strikes the nurse strikes and
the ambulance workers strikes and three
billion is going in we hear originally
uh the government's saying that this
money was going to come from existing
budgets and then it wasn't going to
affect patient care it wasn't going to
come from Frontline Services we now hear
that there's new money going in and the
Ft reports that the government hopes
this will have a snowball effect on
public sector strikes that if the nurses
and the ambulance workers who have quite
a lot of public sympathy uh compared to
for example train drivers or postal
workers or people in the passport office
that this will add some momentum that
will that will stop the strikes but the
thing is you've got Junior doctors who
are still asking for an over 30 percent
hay rise and they're not involved in any
of these discussions you've also got the
teachers at a time when the nut has
instructed its workers to to reject the
latest payoff which is I think 4.5
percent
um and a one-off payment of a thousand
pounds and I think those workers who've
been striking will hope that the
Snowball Effect is on the government's
side that there will be some impetus for
the government to find more money like
they were able to find this three
billion pounds to put into the NHS to
cover the nurses and arguments workers
that they might be able to find a little
bit more to uh fund teachers and perhaps
Junior doctors too yes and the news on
teaching uh seems to be this uh tonight
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
suggesting that teachers could miss out
on an increased pay deal if they reject
the government's offer the National
Education Union
um has urged its members to turn down
that recent offer so that the threats
are there after these offensive talks we
see what happens with that but if we
look at the express you know all of this
all of this winter this difficult winter
for the NHS has certainly had a big
impact a warning siren as the paper puts
it on our attitude to our Health Service
Matt
um yeah that's right it uh quotes um
results from a British attitude survey
uh today showing that satisfaction
levels with the NHS is at an all-time
low of just 29 of people satisfied with
the NHS and the care that they receive
and it's no surprise why is no surprise
really given that uh 7.2 million people
are currently waiting for treatment
three million of those have been waiting
for more than 18 weeks
um and the reasons why um well the
express site um uh 137 000 unfilled
posts uh in the NHS which means that
Staffing levels are very low so the lack
of nurses lack of doctors to care for
patients and so it does paint a very
worrying picture and uh the government
is going to obviously hope that once it
settles the current dispute and and
hopes that uh evidence workers and other
health workers except the five percent
pay rise for this financial year will
try and attract more people into the
Health Service
um but with satisfaction levels so hot
so low
um it's good it's not well friends of
mine who work in Health Services across
different uh sectors they're saying that
uh that their morale has never been
lower because patients are just becoming
incredibly uh difficult with them
and we've had you know any hope of uh of
the strike action
um dwindling
um you know we saw food inflation
figures today I mean extraordinarily
High uh you know another new high a
15-year High grocery inflation hit by
that shortage of fruit and veg and even
though um inflation is annualized so
it'll appear to be going down the cost
will still stay high for people weren't
they Jenny this is the problem that uh
you know that we've got going forward
yes I mean in inflation as in prices
being inflated may slow it may stop well
it's never really going to stop but it
may slow to manageable levels but these
prices are here to stay and when you're
looking at the NHS in particular
um all of this dissatisfaction with the
NHS and you think it was only three
years ago that we were all standing on
our doorsteps and clapping for the NHS
the problem is there has been chronic
under investment in the NHS for a very
long time at this time when we've got a
growing population uh an elderly
population and a social care price uh
crisis and now we've got inflation these
big prices here to stay
um this is an enormous problem and the
strikes are about not just about pay I
mean you had paramedics saying call
handlers saying that they were striking
because of standards of patient care
because they were traumatized because
they were going home uh with the
knowledge that people were being left
with broken hits on the floor and that
they hadn't been able to send Andy and
says out to them so you know the
problems with the NHS run very deep
let's move on to your paper in fact your
article alongside your political editor
Stephen swimford it's also the lead for
the Daily Mail and this is where to put
migrants
um and the suggestion is that a giant
barge is among things being considered
tell us more about this than that
seems to be a revolving door reversed
ideas that come out the home office um
over the last two to three years to
solve this migrant crisis the latest is
that um and and we've we've been
authoritatively told that this is very
much under consideration and they're
looking to procure a giant barge that
are used usually by companies for um
offshore oil rigs to accommodate staff
sort of
um uh 40 to 50 minutes helicopter ride
off the North Coast of Scotland for
example but these under this plan would
be a giant accommodation barge um of
about 300 people accommodate about 300
people in communal rooms at a port no
further details we understand they're
going to be announced tomorrow just the
intention to procure this kind of
accommodation alongside uh disused RF
bases such as the one at scampton the
where the dumb Busters flew from and
also one in Braintree and Essex and but
the whole idea about this is is not to
sort of suddenly move 51 000 Vibrance a
company living in hotels into this um
sort of large-scale accommodation the
the idea the government is trying to get
make tomorrow is um that it's it's to
show sort of if you come here illegally
across the channel in a small boat
you're not going to be put up in a hotel
anymore you're you're going to risk
having to be put up in a a pretty old
military base
um but actually underlying this is the
government um actually accepting that uh
Michigan pledged to move to um the
thousands of markets out of hotels this
year they're going to fail
um because there's just obviously just a
lack of space and so they're just trying
to come up with uh sort of slightly
desperate Solutions um to try and show
that they are making progress towards
ending the crisis there you go Jenny you
come on a small boat you end up on a
disused ship is that a solution
oh it's not a solution at all if I think
the most generous thing that I could say
is that this is uh like the small boats
plan or even like Rwanda itself this is
a concept a concept that they hope will
deter people an idea a headline that
they hope will stop people from risking
their lives to cross the channel because
they once they've risked their lives
they don't like they don't fancy the
idea of that kind of accommodation but
we know that things like this don't work
as a deterrent Rwanda was supposed to be
a deterrent it was announced just over a
year ago and since then we've had record
numbers of people crossing in small
boats these sorts of things don't deter
people and actually this is a completely
unworkable plan these kinds of barges
they're designed for people who work in
oil and gas Rigs and and construction uh
people who know about health and safety
and have been trained in it largely male
workers who are used to living together
in close quarters not families with
women and children all together so
closely it seems like a completely
fanciful idea and I don't think the
government really thinks it's going to
work at all it's another big sparkling
bauble where they can say they're trying
to do something they're being stopped by
activist lawyers or whatever it is that
is supposed to deter people well we all
know that these things don't deter
people they're still going to try and
come unless there is a a a conscious
plan to try and stop them that has been
thought through and isn't against
international law let's head abroad now
for a couple of stories um the Nashville
shooting first of all picture story on
the front page of the Guardian map with
a small child weeping as she's driven
away from the Nashville school where six
people were shot dead including three
nine-year-olds as we know with more
details emerging about the incident
footage of the shooter police body cam
footage too
um and it's you know for us it is so
extraordinary that America keeps going
through these extraordinarily terrible
moments with the trauma that we see
there on the face of that young child
yeah that's right and the uh the footage
from the body comes of the police
officers the five police officers who
arrived on the scene um it was showed
earlier on broadcasters it was really
quite shocking to see um because we hear
about these mass shootings all the time
obviously uh is it now um 130 mass
shootings this year alone I think it is
um that has reached it reached more than
hundreds of for the quickest time
um ever
um and sort of by seeing the images that
we saw in that footage you sort of put
yourself in the classroom going back to
school and just thinking that just the
uh just how terrifying it must be for
for the kids who are age three to eleven
um so it it was really quite shocking
but then it's America and what really
struck home was um when Joe Biden there
um said uh in response to this that um
he hopes the Senate will pass his um
bill that will um a ban assault rifles I
mean if they're only at that stage it
just shows you just how well we might
think in my opinion how far behind they
are in gun legislation compared to us
well certainly our correspondent our us
correspondent tried to track down the
congressman who had posted a sort of
Christmas photo with everybody holding a
salt assault rifles you know in that
sense that the cause is lost it feels
does it not but details emerging about
the shooter Audrey Hale a transgender uh
male now as well and some suggestions
that her parents weren't comfortable
with that
um you know she had issue was being
dealt with for emotional issues they
don't have the red flag system where
you'd a police would take away weapons
you know there's so many elements to
this aren't there
there are so many sort of tragic
shocking things in all of this to drive
a car in America you have to pass a test
and you have to have insurance to have a
gun you don't have to pass any test at
all you don't have to be insured you
don't have to be assessed to be a
capable person there is no red flag
exemption that if you're having uh
treatment for mental health problems you
will be stopped from buying a gun in
States like Tennessee they fight
viciously for the rights of unborn
children they are uh you know large
parts of America and many Republicans
very very anti-abortion And yet when it
comes to children who have been born who
are nine years old and going to school
um they are they are prepared to expose
them to this danger in the name of this
totemic Freedom it is a culture war in
America it is one that we find very
difficult to understand but when we see
those images of those children leaving
their classroom with their hands in the
air enacting for real they're rehearsed
drill the children in America now have
to rehearse you you think this is a
symptom of a really sick society and it
is such a shame it is such a stain on
America that this happens and as Matt
says 130 mass shootings so far this year
we're not even a quarter of the way
through and to qualify to be a mass
shooting there has to be more than four
victims in a random uh assault where
where the victims are not known to the
shooter and there's there's not a theft
involved here it's quite a tight
restriction so this is an absolute
tragedy and it is it's an indictment of
American politics that they cannot get a
grip on it yes one Congressman said to
us earlier today three children had died
through accidental strangling with
lanyards so they banned lanyards and
they can't tackle this in in any shape
or form at the moment anyway we'll keep
her keep pursuing that no doubt lots
more ahead including a massive fine for
the wedding from William Hill over
safeguarding failures we'll have more on
that issue next
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview with me now Jenny cleeman
and Matt dason Matt let's take a look at
the picture story for the financial time
shall we the city of light as Paris is
known becoming the city of fright as the
paper's describing it with the you know
more disruption and demonstrations on
the streets of Paris um something you're
looking at very closely for for personal
reasons yourself
hmm yeah that's right I was meant to be
um running the marathon on Sunday and
having failed it to my trading plan I'm
sort of slightly hoping they canceled it
because of the writing but unfortunately
um according to the Ft the figures the
number of people are turning out has
dropped compared to last week um
although the numbers are still huge 450
000 compared to 800 000 last week and uh
nine out of paris's um universities have
been shut down as more and more
youngsters are joining the protest so no
sign of the writing and protesting uh
going away
fingers crossed fingers well we'll we'll
keep an eye on it for you certainly um
Jenny let's go to William Hill uh told
to pay out a record 19 million pound
penalty
um you know this is this is an issue for
very many people and it's something that
people cover often which is you know the
addiction to betting isn't is enough not
being done is that that's the wrong way
around but you know what I mean
well there's two things that aren't
being done one is this 19.2 million
pound penalty that William Hill is
paying uh doesn't mean that they're
going to lose their license to operate
they're still going to be able to
operate and also you need to put this
19.2 million pounds in context the
gambling industry as a whole in this
country spends about one and a half
billion pounds a year on marketing alone
this is a very wealthy sector these are
very wealthy companies so fines like
this they might sound massive but they
have really big profits and they can
afford them but the main reason uh why
nothing's being done is we've been
waiting for the gambling review which
was supposed to be uh you know it was
supposed to report three years ago uh in
2020 you have incredible bereaved
families who are who speak so eloquently
who so powerfully who have lost loved
ones with gambling addiction to suicide
and uh they have been lobbying for major
reform we haven't had any reform at all
since 2005 before the invention of the
smartphone people people now have
casinos in their pocket and they can
gamble 24 hours a day we urgently need
reform so it's not just fines we need
legislation as well and we also need
gambling firms to have their licenses
revoked when they behave badly yes
interesting quote from the gambling
commission chief executive in the paper
the Metro when we launched this
investigation the failings we uncovered
were so widespread and alarming serious
consideration was given to license
suspension but because the operator
immediately recognized their failings
and worked with us to swiftly Implement
improvements we instead opted for the
largest Enforcement Payment in our
history but a sign how seriously they
they took that
um quick 30 seconds if you don't mind on
the front page of the I and linica one
Taxman nil Matt
yeah this is an appeal going to get
started back in 2019 over a 4.9 million
tax bill and a judge earlier today ruled
that
lineker was a freelancer who had direct
contracts with two broadcasters the BBC
and BT Sport and therefore
um the taxman was wrong to class him as
an effective employee of the BBC uh so
it'll be a sorry relief for the linica
household tonight